hi i'm brad geddes the author of
advanced google adwords the founder of
certified knowledge and the papacy
faculty chair for market motive in this
module we're going to talk about PPC for
the holidays the fundamentals of paid
search campaigns are always necessary
regardless if it's a holiday or typical
day however there are some differences
in traffic patterns that can affect your
marketing during holiday seasons first
we're gonna take a look at the data that
identifies these shifts and consumer
researched piece and traffic so forth
and then examine how to take advantage
of these trends that occur during
holiday seasons
during holidays traffic for specific
Goods often peak if you have peaks and
lows in your sales cycle then you need
to adjust your marketing during these
times so tips we'll be discussing in
this module will help you take advantage
of the peaks in your traffic so you can
make as much money as possible during
these short live bursts of traffic that
help you write out times of normal
versus below normal traffic periods now
what also happens is while holidays
change traffic other seasonal events
change traffic as well at the beginning
of summer often you see a peak in
swimwear at the beginning of the school
season you often see increases in
traffic for backpacks and school
supplies
well technically these are not holidays
they are peaks in traffic and the same
techniques that help you take advantage
of holiday seasonal Peaks can help you
take advantage of any peaks in your
traffic
during the past few years the Internet
has increasingly become a destination
point for holiday sales in 2009 the
economic shift hurt online sales over
the past few years though the Internet
has increasingly become the place of
consumers turn to spend money during
holiday seasons in 2011 the average
shopper not only planes has spent almost
47 percent of the money online they also
plan on spending 36% of their entire
shopping time online so this includes
research as well as buying during these
peaks in consumer interest search
queries go up it's also common to see a
shift in conversion rates that correlate
to these spikes in traffic this makes it
imperative to forecast when these spikes
will occur so you can maximize your
advantage
during these short lift periods of time
now many industries can take advantage
of holiday peace while Christmas is the
most obvious one and the one was talked
about flowers have an increase in search
and conversion rates from Valentine's
Day grills and outdoor cooking peak in
the US around the July 4th holiday
costumes peak right before Halloween
decorations often start just for for
Halloween with Halloween decorations but
continued into November as decoration
searches change from how we know
Thanksgiving and then to Christmas so
being able to identify these trends is
necessary so that you can adjust
marketing when the trends occur for you
so next we're gonna look at some of the
basics of paid search keywords ad copy
landing pages and then see how they
differ during holiday times
now keywords are the foundation of paid
search during the entire year the
industry as a whole is often called
keyword advertising now during holiday
times there's often a shift in the
keywords used by consumers so you need
to make sure you're capturing the search
growth of is additional keywords for
instance a common trend over the past
few years is consumers searching for
deals so one of the most common ways to
search for deals is to include the word
coupon in your search query so this is a
chart of a number of searches for the
word coupon compared to the overall
retail of search growth so retail search
has obvious upward trends during
Christmastime
however this searches for coupon have
larger growth Peaks during the holidays
so users are increasing searching for
deals so make sure your advertising on
coupon words such as your product names
with the word coupon attached to the
word or coupon plus your industry now
these queries go beyond just the word
coupon some other key words to think
about using in your account our discount
sale cheap free shipping fast shipping
bargains inexpensive she's not going to
use these words individually just attach
these words to your typical keyword uses
and make permutations of your current
keywords with discount with cheap with
free shipping so you can capture these
additional search queries
often during holidays searches don't
just look for existing products but they
also turn to search engines for help in
deciding what gifts to actually buy so
you want to add keywords that are more
related to gifts gift-giving
and help consumers shop at your site
when uncertain what they're looking for
these words are often higher in the
shopping cycle you're gonna watch them
closely during non holiday seasons
it's common for words on the Shopping
cycle to have lower conversion rates
then more specific words because
someone's not quite sure they're looking
for yet but these words higher in the
shopping cycle also often have higher
average sale amounts because someone has
it narrowed down to one specific product
yet so it's more common to see cross
sells and upsells for consumers because
they want to be led in a direction for
they should be buying and are often more
open to multi product buying when
they're higher in the sales funnel so
words like Valentine's Day bouquets for
wife Christmas gifts for men just gifts
under $20 Father's Day presents these
aren't individual products these are
searchers who are looking for a product
but don't know what to buy and need your
advice so if you can advertise on these
words instead of the pages I talk about
here are the gifts under $20 here are
some most common Father's Day presents
this will help you take advantage of the
seasonal Peaks for these words so you
can have more words to advertise on get
more consumers and ultimately sell them
additional products
don't forget to take a look at searches
across your site as well to help you
mind for keywords this is a great way of
spotting new trends and interests or
sales from your own data the easiest way
to see converting queries across your
site if you use Google Analytics is the
first segment by visits with conversions
then take a look at your search terms
it's also useful to take a look at
visits without conversions to see if
their search terms that are commonly
used where you don't have a product or
destination page you may want to add
more products based upon consumer
interest
now also during holiday times
double-check your negative keywords
often words like discount coupon and
free and up on negative keyword list
during the course of year now since
these words are often searched during
the holidays you might want to delete
these keywords during holiday times so
if you want to re-enable these negative
keywords after your holiday pikas past
use negative keyword lists so you can
easily apply and then delete these words
from a campaign now sense free shipping
is so common during the holidays be
careful of having a negative keyword
free inside of your account if you sell
TVs and someone searches for plasma TV
with free shipping and you offer free
shipping you probably want to show an ad
fit query even though it contains the
word free so be careful of the word free
as a negative keyword
now past key words we have to also look
at our ad copy for holiday periods your
ads serve as that bridge from the search
query to your website so as consumer
mindsets change during the holiday
seasons your ads may also need to change
to take advantage of these search trends
so the first place you want to start is
looking at your site links everybody
should be using site links period they
allow you to take up more real estate
with your ad copy and show additional
messages to consumers during the holiday
season take advantage of these site
links just show special promotional
messages such as free discounted or
guaranteed shipping links right into
gift guides top rated gifts gifts under
ten or twenty dollars and even benefit
messages
don't underestimate site links go often
they don't get a lot of clicks
individually they can often increase the
ads overall click-through rates
now if you sell physical goods online
the easiest way to promote many of these
Goods directly into the search results
is to use the product extension with
this extension you need a Google
Merchant Center account then you need to
upload a feed that contains your
products to the Merchant Center account
now many shopping carts have an easy way
to export a product list that can be
imported into the Merchant Center so the
next connect your Merchant Center
account to your AdWords account for each
campaigns where you want this extension
displayed so if you're currently using
Google Merchant Center but not taking
advantage of product extensions it
should only take you a few minutes to
enable this extension then you can show
your products in images of your products
directly on Google search page a page
that doesn't have a lot of images this
is a place to really get a lot more
visibility for various products
if you're a retail business with
physical locations you want to use the
location extension the easiest way to
enable this extension is to create a
Google Places account and everybody
weather uses extension or not should
clean your Google Places account for all
of your locations then put your data
into Google Places then just connect
your Google Places account to your
AdWords account with the AdWords
location extension once these two are
connected your Google Places in Adwords
then a map and driving Direction options
can be displayed directly in the ad copy
this is a great way to show consumers
exactly where you're located so they can
stop in your store when they're out
holiday shopping
now throughout the year the searcher is
usually the product user as a result
your benefit messages inside of your ad
copy are generally focused on the
searcher during holidays this is not
true during holidays the searcher is the
buyer but they're not the recipients of
the product so you're gonna want to
focus your benefit messages around the
benefits for the searcher who's the
buyer not the recipient or the gift
receiver so prices discount offers free
discounted shipping gift wrapping
personalized cards quick shipping
options those are great ways to think
about benefits that are for the consumer
that may not benefit the recipient but
the consumer is the one who's paying you
don't forget to also create a sense of
urgency free shipping until December
23rd or February 13th is the deadline
for out-of-town flower delivery or order
your grill by July 1st for the perfect
life with Burgers holidays have exact
dates they occur so as it gets closer to
the date make sure you're creating a
sense of urgency so they know there's a
deadline they have to hit and they need
to spend this money and give you more
money than before this deadline
if you'd like to test out some new ads
some benefit messages or landing pages
during the holiday season but you're
worried how these new ads might cut into
your profits after all not every test
will work then use ace or AdWords
campaign experiments to run your tests
with ace you can designate a percentage
of times you wish your test ads or your
test ad groups to run so you can still
do ad copy testing but only show these
new test ads 30% of a time that way
you're jeopardizing a small percentage
of revenue then look at the results and
if your test ads do better and of course
go ahead and enable those for the rest
of the time to show
now first we have our keywords which
makes for ad show then we have our ad
copy which brings in qualify traffic now
your landing pages job is taking invent
someone to actually buy and spend money
so in this section we'll look at landing
pages and some changes you might want to
use during holiday periods so the first
row of landing pages regardless if it's
holiday or typical year is that landing
pages should give the consumer the
answer to their search query or show
them how to get the answer in terms of
buying a product now someone searched
because they want the answer to a
question and your landing page is the
starting place for that quest so it
should be close to related search query
however you need to go beyond just just
answer users question to maintain sense
between the ad copy and the landing page
if you make a promise in your ad such as
free shipping discount codes 50% off
make sure your landing page has that
same offer and that it's prominent on
the page so someone sees your ad 50% off
the ascend your landing page a few
percent off there's no confusion then
about the offered how to take advantage
of the offer another thing to test out
for holiday times that often free
shipping does really well sometimes even
better than sales I've seen times we're
offering free shipping does better than
10% off even when free shipping will
save you $9 and tampers off we'll say 15
free shipping is a really important one
during holiday periods
but also during the holidays often users
don't really know what to buy
so creating holiday guides for various
genders age ranges and price points is a
good idea you can point up these guides
on category pages or specials across
your site but if you do buy keywords
such as gifts for men under $25 just for
females gifts for the wife
make sure those words are going to the
buying guide for that query so by
creating guides and buying keywords
related to the guides you can follow
people who don't know if they want yet
into a specific section of goods and
sell more overall products
now upsells and cross-sells can also
increase your average order value if you
have your own previous data on upsells
use that and designing across those
sections but if you're uncertain and
you're not sure what price points or
what products to add on your cross sell
pages a general rule that works pretty
well is that you should upsell a product
to a maximum cost point of 60 percent of
the current product for instance if you
think of someone buying a tie then you
can cross sell a matching handkerchief a
belt maybe a tie clip but you can't sell
someone an entire suit or an expensive
shirt now if someone does buy a suit
then you can cross out an expensive
shirt or a matching tie because they
spent more money on the suit initially
another great use of upsells from the
holiday season is gift wrapping or
personalized cards so a good test to run
is what happens if you do an upsell of
Grif trapping versus even offer it as a
free additional benefit does the
additional benefit a free gift wrapping
increase conversion rates enough to
offset the fact you're giving away a
service so that's something else to
think about during holidays is gift
wrapping and personalized cards but also
offer gift cards gift cards have huge
spikes during Christmas time however
they're also often bought around
birthdays wedding times baby showers
graduation and mothers and fathers day
often gift cards are an easier
cross-sell than a specific product as
the user can just specify a price amount
for a gift card and not have to worry
about hunting for very specific products
that fit into their price points
the holidays to occur on specific dates
and no one wants their gifts to be
delivered late so just have a page that
shows your shipping schedule so someone
can tell they have to order by this date
to be able to get their gift on time so
be careful of just saying things like we
can get your present there by December
24th many people travel during the
holidays they might need their presence
to get there by the 22nd so they can
take them with them if you only say we
can still get there about 24th you
haven't really spoken to the traveling
person who needs stuff earlier your
landing page and website needs to
convince a user to buy from you the
easier it is to find information whether
it's shipping guides gift guides so
forth and the easier it is to buy a
product from you as well better your
sales should be during holiday periods
now holiday times bring about higher
search volume and often higher bids as
well so in this section we'll examine a
few items to keep an eye on to make sure
you're able to capture all of the
relevant traffic to your business so
what happens during holiday times is
that cost per clicks and bids increase
due to more advertisers wanting to
capture the increase search of volume so
on the surface that might not seem
profitable if you're already bidding
based upon return on investment or ROA
as for some metric you've devised then
you don't want to just bid more because
there's a volume increase but if your
conversions also increase and your
conversion rate increases then you do
want to bid more so if you have last
year's data study it carefully because
often what happens during holiday times
is while cpc's go up conversion rates
also go up which means your CPA your
cost per action can still be lower even
at a higher CPC so if you have this
added ask yourself questions such as do
flour conversions increase 10% or 30%
two days before Valentine's Day
Jebus sales explosion on Cyber Monday
but the next Tuesday conversions go back
to normal
therefore you might want increase your
bids for just a day or two then lower
them back to more normal levels before
you find the next increase in conversion
rate so if you have the data use it
however if you don't have a circle data
then watch your conversions very closely
in fact you might want to just sit down
and do some research about the top days
for you to make out a clear calendar
these days should be spikes in traffic
therefore we're hoping our CPA goes down
our covers rate goes up a little bit
more these days we think traffic will
return to normal so let's reset our bids
make a plan of how you want to change
your cpc's because what you don't want
to do during peak days is use just last
week or last month's data because that
does not give you a good indicator of
how the peaks are going to occur and how
you're coming
version rates will shift so if you have
last year's data at great use that for
holidays if you don't make some good
guesses about how to increase cpc's
office some estimated conversion rate
increases
now if also you don't have all this data
and you're not sure how to make all
these guesstimates then you might just
want to test out Google's conversion
optimizer with Google conversion
optimizer you must be using AdWords
conversion track and you must meet a
minimum number of conversions each month
if you have these numbers then you can
turn on conversion optimizer and Google
will take over the bidding for you and
attempting to get the most conversions
possible for your target or your max
cost per action so this is a really good
compromise if you normally like a lot of
control but you don't know how to how to
guess your bids so if you have a lot of
conversions but don't have much
historical data then relay in Google's
bid technology instead of a lot of
guesswork to try to grab as many
conversions as possible during the
holidays
now with conversion optimizer or even
your preferred bidding system that just
sets the bids for your keywords there's
another setting that's useful to get the
most conversions possible when the ad
does show then normally throughout the
year you'll be doing a lot of testing of
ads you'll probably use the rotate
function most often real show ad 1 then
2 then 3 back to 1 again to get a lot of
data across multiple tests to pick your
winner however during peak times these
times don't last very long you really
want to grab as many conversions
possible in that short amount of time so
there's another setting called optimized
for conversions show ads expected to
produce the most conversions so Google
is going to look at your ads your ad
conversion rates and in your keyword so
forth to serve the ads with the highest
conversion rate the most so this is a
good way during holiday seasons to grab
a few more conversions when you don't
want to do a huge amount of testing well
you don't have the time because you're
doing all this other stuff related
holiday seasons then during the rest of
the year do your more typical conversion
testing on your ad copies
you'll also want to watch your budgets
very closely as holidays bring about
more traffic there's a lot more clicks
we captured but you have to have a large
enough budget to capture these
additional clicks so the easiest way to
see if you're losing impressions due to
budget is to look at the lost impression
share budget percentages for your
campaigns so you can access this data
from the campaign's tab and if you don't
see it then hit the customize columns
link and then look under the competitive
metrics and add your impression share in
lost impression budget data so once you
save these columns then you'll see
impressions share for the campaigns and
the reasons either budget of rank
you're losing impressions if you're
losing a precious suitor rank then you
need to raise your a drink which is a
combination of bid and a quality score
but if you're losing impressions due to
budgets just by raising your budgets you
should be able to capture more
impressions
it's also useful to look beyond just
search and see how the display network
can also increase your conversions
during holiday seasons according to
consumer brahmer approximately 53% of
retail information is found via search
engines another 18% is found on to
consumer review sites and then smaller
percentages are found on places like
blogs forums and other content sites you
can reach these non search sites through
the Google Display Network in fact
according to Google 80% a medium
advertiser conversions are from search
and 20% are from Display now I've seen
many examples where display conversions
are actually much much higher than that
but enabling display campaigns can help
you reach more consumers during the
entire year but especially during
holiday season when these sites also see
traffic spikes as people are looking for
more product information gift guides and
other info before making purchases if
you have previously paused your display
campaigns you should give them another
try during holiday seasons
if you've not used the Google Display
Network often and it sort of on
accustomed to choosing keywords for the
network the contextual targeting tool
can give you a quick jump start this
tool shows you keywords related to an
idea gives you approximate cpc's and you
can even get a list of websites where
your ads can be displayed so this is a
quick way to build several display ad
groups so you can take advantage of the
Display Network even that previously
worked and tested what keywords go per
ad group so you can target appropriately
if you're looking for a broad reach
across the display network or if you
don't have the time to pick and choose
all your keywords topic targeting can
give you a display boost with topic
targeting you can choose topics and then
let Google figure out where to put your
ads on sites related to that topic with
topic targeting please try and be as
specific as possible when you choose
topics choosing the apparel topic will
give you a huge reach but it's not going
to be a very targeted reach if you
choose just a formal wear for one ad
group you can create an ad copy related
to formal wear if in another ad group
you choose just children's clothing
topic targeting then you can make an
Advil ADA to just children's clothing so
with display you still want to make sure
that your targets your ad copies and
your landing pages are still close
related to each other just as with
search
another tool that Google Offers that
will help you advertise across the
Google Display Network is the display ad
builder this tool lets you quickly
create display ads that you can show on
these various sites across this play
Network what's nice about the tool so
there's a lot of pre created themes you
can start with and then you can
customize them to showcase your products
many of these themes are related to
holidays there's Christmas Valentine's
Day Presidents Day ads that are related
to specific holidays
there's also edge with it's more
ambiguous time frames where you may see
traffic spikes such as spring summer or
winter so using graphical ads across the
Display Network can not only bring in
traffic but just display the ads also
make sure more consumers are seeing your
brand during peak seasons holidays bring
about an increase in search they also
cause an inflation and consumer research
as well so by using the Display Network
you just build increase your total
conversions during holiday season by
reaching people who are on non search
sites doing research about gift buying
or just your products in general
now remarketing is very effective across
the entire year and there's a set of
guidelines around best practices in
using remarketing during the year
however during peak research times you
might break a few of these rules as
traffic is just different for holiday
periods than the rest of the year
now's remarketing is still fairly new
and it's way underused first we do a
quick recap about remarketing and then
talk about how to use it so what
marketing does is allow you to serve an
ad across Google's Display Network to
those who are previously on your site
you do not have to target keywords or
topics you can target individuals who
are previously on your site censure and
marketing campaign structures are based
upon your site and not your keywords
first examine your website look for
areas that people visit that indicate
they're interested in various products
for instance if someone who visits your
homepage they've not gone any further in
your site it might not care too much
about your products but if someone's
gone into your category pages are better
at your product pages then you might
want to serve ads back to those users as
they spent more time on your site do
more research and we're more interested
in your products so think about your
site's overall structure it's also
useful to have your analytics open at
the same time as you need to set 500
cookies or have 500 people in a list
before a marketing list can go active
you'll still want your ads and landing
pages to be similar to the section some
was on your site so for instance if some
was on your your women's section you
don't want to show luggage ads if
they're in the girls section you want to
show as what's a girl's clothing so
first take a look at your site structure
how many visits each section of your
site gets in a time period then to
determine how you want to remarket back
to consumers so your ads and your
categories are close related to each
other
once you've determined how you wanna set
up your ad groups based upon your ads
your site structure then you need to go
into the audience section of AdWords and
create a list for each one of these
sections when you create a list you can
also set up a cookie duration and name
the list so you have an idea what it's
about once you create a list Google is
going to give you a code this is the one
of the average conversion tracking code
this code only should go on the pages
where you want someone who visits that
page to be associated to that list so
for instance if you have a men's section
a women's section and a children's
section you'll define three less one
men's on women when children you'll have
three codes one will only go in the
men's section one only goes in the
women's section one only goes in the
children's section that way you can
segment your audience based upon where
they are on your site now first do this
immediately because this starts
collecting the cookies themselves to
build up your list sizes when you're
ready to go ahead and create ads for
these lists then you'll go to an ad
group under the audiences tab you can
define what lists the user is in and you
can have both negative and positive list
just like keywords so once you create
your ad groups the right ad copy that
goes along with the list so for instance
if you have set up a list for men's
clothing women's clothing and children's
clothing set up three a groups that way
each a group has just that lists in it
and appropriate ad copy now for the
holiday season it's useful to include
dates and key selling points so for
instance remember to order by December
23rd for Christmas delivery err or we
can do same-day flower delivery for
Valentine's Day etc now with remarketing
Google does have some pretty strict
guidelines about user privacy and how
you can do some ads so please do take a
look at their guidelines to make sure
not violating any of them the best place
to put
a remarketing code is on the shopping
cart page people who shopped across your
site added items to their cart got your
checkout page and then didn't convert
that's when your most valuable prospects
for remarketing you should target these
users separately from the rest of your
site as often you'll be willing to pay
more for one of these consumers to come
back to your site as opposed to someone
who just visited your homepage or
category page so if you make abandoned
shoppers or own lists you can serve them
specific ad text and set separate bids
from just someone who is on a different
section of your website now normally
during the year you'll also want a list
on your thank-you page as you might not
want to remark that back to those who
converted so you set a cook in your
thank-you page and you put that in your
negative list or you might want to
market back to them a month or so after
they shopped to remind them about their
good experience on your site and try to
increase lifetime visitor values by
showing ads back to these users after a
period of time during holiday seasons
it's useful to be just a bit more
aggressive remarketing to converters
then during the rest of the year if
someone has a good experience on your
site and they still need something they
haven't bought all their gifts they need
to buy another flower bouquet whatever
it is make sure your ad is still there
when they need something similar again
so during holiday season you'll often
raise your frequency caps for
remarketing and even offer specials to
those who converted once to incentivize
them to return to your sites so during
the rest of the year remarketing asking
oh but creepy need to control them or
frequency capping you can raise those
caps during holiday seasons the one
thing to remember marketing is that you
have to have 500 cookies set before a
list will go active so it's useful just
to set and collect cookies for your
lists even if you're on active or your
marketing by collecting the cookies when
you're ready now to serve an ad then you
already have a list with
people in it she can immediately start
serving these in addition what you will
find is that you'll want to adjust
messages as the holiday approaches for
instance for holidays for weeks away you
might want one benefit message at the
two week mark the holidays getting close
you might want to focus a bit more on
prices or discounts when it's a week
away you might want to focus more on
shipping for that last-minute shopper so
you don't want to keep changing your
lists here you just want different ads
to show to someone based upon the
current date so what you can do then is
just go write several ads your ad groups
ones you want wive at the four week mark
the two week mark the one week mark that
the day of Dizz based upon your holiday
times in your products and then pause
these additional ends Google reviews
paused ads so these ads should be
reviewed hopefully approved and then you
set a reminder to yourself that it's a
week before the holiday
pause add one on pause add to that we're
changing your message is based upon
benefits and time frames so we're
marketing is a very powerful way that
you can serve as the people who already
know your brand they already know your
site by planning out and executing
marketing campaigns you can remark it
back to converters to increase select a
visitor value or we mark it back to non
converters to increase your total
conversions during holiday seasons
our mobile usage is on the rise for both
tablets and smartphones you should be
showing ads to mobile users during the
holidays in fact the National Retail
Federation did a survey asking people
how they would use mobile devices during
the holidays the top answer was to
research products and compare prices the
second most common was for purchasing
products
the third was coupon Redemption then
looking at locations and then finally
using apps for research and purchasing
this means that both brick-and-mortar
and online only stores can use mobile
campaigns to their advantage if you have
a physical store they need to showcase
coupons and locations if you're an
online only store then of course use
coupons as well and make it easy for
mobile purchases on your site both
brick-and-mortar and online only can
include information about products for
product research purposes as well so
it's important that you have a mobile
presence during holiday season
now for mobile devices often the
keywords are shorter than on desktops so
to do mobile keyword research the
Adwords Keyword tool is a great place to
start under the Advanced Options you can
choose to segment mobile only so you're
only seeing search data for mobile
devices
if you have a physical store make sure
you're using location extensions so that
consumers can easily get driving
directions from their phone or tablet
and see maps of where you are located
you'll often want to focus on seeing
their products touching the products
something you can do in a physical place
you can't do online and the benefits of
in-person service pick up your present
today and take it home with you now if
you're an online retailer then you're
going to focus more on price comparison
and free shipping for your mobile ads as
mobile is on the rise and it's not
slowing down having a mobile presence in
both the ads and a nice mobile
compatible site has really become a
necessity for anyone who wants to
capture mobile traffic and often
holidays drive an increase in mobile
traffic and there's good traffic to be
had on mobile devices
there are a few other things just to
consider before we look at a wrap-up of
the key points to remember so first
don't stop advertising just after the
holidays there are those who look for
cheap costumes just after Halloween they
look for after Christmas specials they
buy their grills on July 6th from the
leftover sales inventory you don't want
to use your existing yet pains our
holiday focus for these consumers but
you can use similar keywords and just
change your ads more focus on post
holiday shopping it also happens is the
closer to a holiday the less
discriminating the shopper becomes the
shopper goes from finding the perfect
gift to something that's just good
enough so even if you run out of the
latest and greatest gifts continue
marketing to similar items as other
retailers will also run out or sometimes
prices spike as the man goes up with
imagery drops so continued advertising
through the entire holiday also don't
forget a lot of people travel for
holidays it's really common so just make
sure you don't make the really common
mistake of saying we can still get your
present by December 24th that's not good
enough for a traveler so just remember a
lot of people do travel so often
focusing on the latest date is not a
good idea until it becomes closer to the
latest Dayton every other tire has
pretty much passed
so some things to remember first off on
keywords make sure you add discount
keywords things like coupon sales add
topical keywords valentine's day
presents gifts for men and check your
negative keywords especially if you have
a negative keyword free for your ad copy
use ad extensions site links location
extensions product extensions are using
the 3 best for holiday seasons and make
sure you're focusing your benefits for
the buyer not the product user free
landing pages maintain your ad copy
sense if you make a promise in your ad
make sure it's on the landing page and
gift buying guides are wonderful for
people who are shopping who don't really
know what they want yet tell them what
they should be buying now keep an eye on
your bids and budgets during holiday
season especially your impression shared
loss to the budget if you're making
money don't have your ads stopped at 4
in the afternoon raise your budgets
you're going to do more anticipations
of beta and conversion changes in
conversion optimizer and the focus on
conversion setting for your ad copy
display are good features of AdWords to
examine for holiday seasons for the
Display Network enable your display
campaigns they're great to run during
holidays but also use display ad builder
so that you're using topical ads and the
your ads showcase winter or Christmas or
Valentine's Day remarketing is great for
holiday season is great all year but for
holiday season you might break a few
rules you may increase your frequency
caps during holiday season but start
remarketing now at least from the fact
of grabbing the cookies and putting
people into s then change your ads as
necessary to focus on holiday benefits
and remarket bow to converters and non
converters in different ad groups with
appropriate messages make a mobile
campaign and make a separate campaign
just for mobile use location extensions
or product extensions based upon your
business type and then do keyword
research just for mobile users having a
separate mode
we'll campaign and then tracking that
data closely can let you see just how
good mobile can be over holiday seasons
and remember don't stop marketing just
after a holiday after the holidays
switch your statements from holiday
sales to after holiday sales and also
the closer to the holiday the more
someone changes from good enough versus
the best if it's a long ways away they
often want the best presence as a
holiday approaches people want a good
enough presence so the best practices of
paid search are the same throughout the
entire year if your keywords cause
relevant ads to show Rovin ads leave the
landing pages that answer that query
then track your conversion set your bids
etc these are best practices regardless
of seasonality factors but during
holiday seasons traffic spikes
conversion rates often increase cost per
actions often decrease by seeing when
this is going to happen for you and
anticipating changes to keywords ads
landing pages budgets and bits you can
capture these additional queries bring
more people to your site and have more
revenue and profits at the end of the
holiday season just by following some
late tips we've looked at